the main motivation for me to switch
over to building passive houses
is that it's just a better product
it has all kinds of great benefits for
the environment but all the things that
makes these homes really energy
efficient also happens to make them
really comfortable they're healthier to
be in they're more resilient when i
heard about the passport standard and
the promise of saving 80 to 90 percent
on heating and cooling cost and 70
of
overall energy usage i just thought well
this is where we need to go this is
where the industry needs to go no
question it doesn't make any sense to
build the way we do now
we're currently 12 people we built
two to three residential homes a year
some light commercial we've seen
probably close to like a tenfold in
interest in the last couple of years
a passive house
is a home that is built to the passenger
house standard which is a german
developed energy standard which is all
related to how much energy the house is
using and to the air tightness of the
home so every single home we built is
kind of rooted in that building science
and they all have the principles of a
passive house in them they don't all
reach the passive house standard but you
can still build a home that's really
efficient
and has all these benefits
so this project is you know it's going
to have the
the principles of a passive house if
you're looking up in the roof
construction here so you can see like
when we're talking about super
insulation
and you know thermal bridging avoiding
thermal bridges you can see how we have
these tj eyes so we're not having like
traditional wooden rafter that goes all
the way through the building we just
have this thin little web and in this
project we're using cellulose insulation
so
it's basically recycled newspaper that
we insulate with so it's one of those
products that has like a low carbon
footprint it's better for the
environment air tightness is really
important if when you're looking on the
outside you can see that before we even
started building anything
we had already put down strips of
membrane when you're building a passive
house compared to a traditional home
the way that it changes the process is
front loading the design process you
really want to iron out the vast
majority of details if we are talking
about environmental benefits you
definitely want to look at the overall
energy consumption of the house but even
more important is looking at the
materials that you're using within the
house because
some products are really energy
intensive to produce
whereas other products have a very low
carbon footprint
all right
in the beginning when we started
building it was tough to get certain
materials there were limited window
manufacturers that make like triple pane
windows now most of the materials and
the technology is really available if
you're building a single family
home i would say it's probably about 10
more to build it compared to a
traditionally built home if you're
building like big commercial buildings
or multi-unit apartment buildings i
think it's probably a break even it does
cost much more
to build this way i think the reason
we're not seeing an explosive growth in
north america i think telling people
that we want to do stuff differently and
changing the way you operate your
business the industry is really slow to
move so
that was probably among the first 50
passengers built in the united states
not sure how many past houses there are
in the u.s right now but i would think
you know probably tens of thousands by
this point i would imagine
the way most people built houses
nowadays are still kind of like
what you did in the 80s it's kind of
like building an old car with like old
technology when there's new technology
that's right here i think passive houses
will definitely continue to be a
reliable source of income i don't see
ever turning back to the way we used to
build compared to other buildings i know
we're seeing like an insane increase in
traffic and interest in our products so
passive houses will play a huge role in
the future of building and one piece of
the parcel for architecture to deal with
climate change
[Music]
you